alors quand je suis sorti du plateau
hier dans le hall derrière le studio
j'ai vu je vais dire le clan l'équipe de
Madame Stevenson il était 6 ou 7 et moi
même si le le la conversation avait été
difficile avec elle j'ai dit bonjour et
là je me suis trouvé avec quelqu'un de
vraiment verbalement très menaçant alors
je j'emploie pas son temps mais c'était
toi tu nous dis pas bonjour et cetera
c'est détaché du groupe à tel point que
la sécurité est arrivée moi je suis
parti j'ai rien ajouté au moment ensuite
où je suis sorti c'est très rare ça
m'arrive très rarement la sécurité m'a
appelé et là la sécurité m'a dit à ce
moment-là Gilles fait très attention on
a empêché quelqu'un de prendre un
scooter pour te suivre tu devrais être
suivi par un véhicule de marque
française de couleur blanche demande
bien à ton taxi de faire plusieurs tours
etc de pas rentrer chez toi directement
cette personne menaçante a été
identifiée je vais pas donner son nom
mais ce qui m'a sidéré c'est que c'est
un journaliste reporter d'image cette
personne qui m'a mené est un journaliste
qui n'avait pas l'autorisation de
rentrer qui s'est mêlé au groupe qui est
rentré et qui était pour je vous le dise
vous savez moi il y a bon rien de mes
frais il était vraiment très très
agressif et j'ai trouvé qu'il y avait
une agressivité dans l'équipe de Madame
Stevenson qui dépasse le cadre du débat
normal c'est elle voulait parler avec
vous quand j'ai essayé d'intervenir elle
voulait pas ok ça ça c'était le deal ok
ok j'ai dit ok ça peut rien dire donc
elle a le droit rien à dire mais après
j'ai trouvé qu'il y avait une
agressivité qui n'avait pas lieu d'être
franchement alors ici on a vu on a vu
l'histoire alors c'est simple pour
mélodie qui était sur notre version qui
était hier sur notre plateau elle avait
ramené des images de vidéosurveillance
nous allons revoir c'est simple pour
elle c'est noana qui est immédiatement
qui a été immédiatement qu'il a agressé
elle se garait simplement quand il est
arrivé alors on voit ces images derrière
parce que j'aimerais que tu rime vous
êtes une proche de teen W vous nous
disiez pourquoi et c'est ce que tout le
monde se demande pourquoi elle se gare
en fait c'est pas c'est pas la même
version en fait ce gars et c'est
pourquoi il va ouvrir la porte de la
voiture derrière s'il vous plaît bah
mettez la scène en boucle en entier s'il
vous plaît merci oui alors déjà toute
chose bonsoir
j'aimerais vous dire me concernant que
vous pourrez me poser toutes les
questions que vous souhaitez
je suis venue ce soir en tant que témoin
et agressé
je suis pas venu vous raconter ma vérité
mais la vérité car il y en a qu'une et
concernant donc la question que vous me
posez Cyril docteur Renan en fait n'est
pas venu voir Madame Stevenson parce que
c'est ce qu'on voit sur les images et on
le voit en fait qu'il essaie d'ouvrir la
porte parce qu'en fait la cible première
du docteur Wana c'est la voiture c'est
le moteur c'est le bruit c'est pas il
l'a même pas vu c'est à dire qu'il est
passé à côté il a même pas vu car il y
avait encore son frère mettez la scène
si vous suivez dans la voiture avec la
musique et le moteur et là le frère il
est dehors non mais avant ça
et est-ce qu'on va pas c'est quoi la
vidéo dure beaucoup plus longtemps là
les couper mais elle dure beaucoup plus
longtemps
parce que si neona disait ici ce n'est
que il était venu il avait tapé à sa
fenêtre et qu'après elle était sortie
mais c'est pas ce qu'on voit là sur les
réseaux après faut savoir que docteur
Rona est venu le lendemain de
l'agression il était encore vraiment
l'état de choc clairement
il est il a quand même subi une heure et
demie d'anesthésie enfin il était même
dans ses propos lors de son de son
pardon de son procès-verbal à la police
il était il bafouillé il disait qu'il la
connaissait vraiment depuis 15 ans enfin
il était un peu perdu dans ce qu'il
disait et il a reconnu et même là quand
on quand il a quand il a il a redit
l'effet réellement il a clairement dit
que non enfin il savait il se souvenait
même pas de ce qu'il avait dit mais donc
oui parce que c'est pas la version c'est
pas qu'il est devenu à la voiture il est
venu juste il est rentré dans la voiture
pour essayer d'enlever le pour vous
mélodie nous dit rien qu'il avait eu des
mots extrêmement durs envers elle est-ce
que vous étiez là vous moi je suis
arrivé juste après donc ils étaient à
cette position là j'avais entendu ce qui
se sont dit quand ils sont croisés donc
le docteur Wana on le voit donc faire
des gestes il dit clairement que il y a
des patientes en haut qui se plaignent
c'est pas la première fois qu'elle
rentre on va on l'entend rentrer dans le
square donc c'est pas la première fois
il disait en fait je pense que c'était
la goutte d'eau là qui a fait déborder
le vase et que c'était la fois de trop
et qu'est-ce que vous dites aux gens qui
disent qu'il a pas ouvrir sa voiture
voilà qu'est-ce que vous leur dit ben je
leur dis tout simplement que il a il
avait une cible une target si vous
voulez vraiment le moteur la voiture
c'est à dire qu'elle il la voit même pas
mais quand elle nous dit que elle hier
le moteur était éteint donc elle elle
nous manque quand elle nous dit ça c'est
facile de venir sur le plateau bien sûr
non mais c'est facile de venir avec une
vidéo qui a pas de son enfin on dirait
alors hier c'était un film Charlie
Chaplin on est venu raconter une
histoire alors que franchement il y
avait pas de son donc on peut tout
inventer et j'ai été là donc franchement
c'est elle a dit que sinon on avait
préféré des insultes racistes envers
elle
est-ce que vous avez entendu ça c'est
très grave je suis choqué encore
aujourd'hui docteur Wellin n'a prononcé
enfin ces mots negresses sale noir il
n'a jamais dit ça j'étais là et c'est ce
qui c'est ce qui me c'est ce qui me
choque le plus il a jamais dit il a
jamais tenu ses propos il a même pas
insulté tandiska elle nous a insulté
elle nous a craché dessus et je le dis
j'ai une vidéo qui le prouve après et
vous nous avez craché dessus sec qui
nous a agressé donc c'est facile de
venir encore une fois avec une vidéo qui
a pas de son et de d'inventer tout ce
qu'on veut alors je vais demander à
Guillaume toi tu as été convaincu par
mélodie donc tu peux le dire oui après
si on se base sur les deux témoignages
qui ont été livrés sur ce plateau moi
j'ai envie de croire mélodie parce que
déjà j'ai trouvé qu'il y avait un fossé
entre ce que racontait cinémonna et les
images qu'on a découvert hier soir et
ensuite sur le fond j'ai trouvé que
cinémas s'attardait sur des détails qui
n'avaient pas grand chose à voir avec la
scène il parlait beaucoup de la Ferrari
comme si ça l'exaspéré il mettait
beaucoup en avant le fait que mélodie
Stevenson était en couple avec un homme
d'affaires fortuné comme si elle profite
son argent on a senti que ça l'exercice
on a aussi quelle est la question que tu
as posé arrive non mais c'est est-ce que
c'est un règlement de compte personnel
plus qu'autre chose j'ai trouvé très
vindicatif là où mélodie était plus
factuel dans sa description des faits en
tout cas sur ce qu'elle a dit sur ce
plateau absolument pas franchement on la
croise jamais enfin docteur Ronan encore
moins avec tout le travail qu'il a il
l'a crois jamais on la croise jamais moi
je vais vous dire il y a un truc on va
voir les images de de l'agression
derrière regarder mes télés moi ce qui
me
c'est la question que tout le monde m'a
posé on voit qu'elle a son frère à côté
d'elle pourquoi et il les laisse
s'embrouiller les deux pourquoi il
n'intervient pas ça c'est un truc j'ai
pas compris en fait et ça c'est parce
que c'était pas embrouillé avant est-ce
qu'il y a pas autre chose dans cette
histoire parce que on comprend pas non
il y a franchement il y a rien et c'est
vrai que moi j'ai été choqué du
comportement de son frère parce que en
fait elle s'est servi lui comme un
bouclier tout simplement c'est à dire
que moi elle m'envoyait des coups à
gauche elle allait voir docteur on est à
droite enfin d'en profiter moi mon frère
a fait à sa place il m'aurait si j'avais
été en situation justement de danger mon
frère m'aurait prise et m'aurait enfin
on serait rentré à la maison qui se
connaissait bien peut-être il se disait
ils se connaissent bien non pas du tout
la première fois
il a lancé une pétition pour qu'elle
déménage c'est ça
pour dans tous les cas elle est même pas
domicilié on se croirait c'est son
conjoint d'accord
ça c'est une fausse info non pas
les sceptiques je sais qu'il y a
également Daniel qui se posent des
questions et qui font la version de
mélodie ce qui m'a gêné c'est vraiment
ce décalage on a l'impression que c'est
lui qui est tout le temps dans le dans
le vindicatif dans le presque dans
l'agression quand même et qu'elle essaie
de se défendre moi je ne regarde que les
images j'entends ce que vous dites j'ai
entendu les deux versions vraiment si je
me fais aux images et au discours il y a
quelque chose qui fonctionne pas et elle
nous a parlé aussi de la l'altercation
qui avait eu l'après-midi donc on a
est-ce qu'il y a pas justement une
espèce de revanche le soir est-ce qu'il
y avait pas quand même elle est pas
anodine c'est absolument pas après
encore une fois moi je suis venu en tant
que témoin agressé je suis pas venu de
défendre doctor wanna ou défendre bien
sûr mais non non il y a pas eu de
l'éducation avant ou Valérie vous aviez
eu vente de l'agression qui avait eu
lieu dans l'après-midi on dit que
docteur anna était venu dire que elle
avait agressé une femme de du quartier
avec un couteau est-ce que c'est vrai
est-ce que c'est faux que qu'est-ce qui
parce qu'en fait après l'altercation
donc la voisine est arrivée donc celle
qui a appelé la police et qui a dit
Sidney tu es la deuxième victime et du
coup donc docteur Ronal comprend pas
trop il a encore un peu sous le choc et
lui dit mais je comprends pas et elle
lui répète que cet après-midi elle a
agressé elle était en compagnie de son
chien et qu'elle a menacé de mort avec
un couteau enfin voilà alors
il y a énormément de gens qui agissent
et beaucoup de gens disent que la
version des faits de ciné correspondent
pas aux images pourquoi parce que drone
ice c'est perdu quand il disait voilà je
suis descendu en tenue de bloc c'est
faux moi je l'ai vu ouais mais ça je
peux comprendre moi je l'ai vu c'est ça
qui nous a oui bien sûr c'est pour ça
que moi je l'ai vu j'étais à l'étage en
fait je l'ai vu effaré descendre en
remettant sa chemise sa chemise de
civile en fait et j'ai vu que ce passage
là en descendant les escaliers il est
descendu et je comprends qu'il y a plein
de petites incohérences moi je suis
spectatrice je comprendrais enfin je me
dis mais c'est c'est pas normal parce
qu'il a dit qu'il avait tapé au cas au
cas où c'est ce que disent les gens je
vous disent qu'ils disent qu'il avait
topocaro on le voit plutôt arriver alors
elle sort de la voiture il se croit donc
c'est ça c'est ça en fait qui même au
niveau enfin quand il a déposé plainte
le lendemain enfin non deux jours après
lors de la confrontation il se souvenait
même pas d'avoir dit ça alors dire que
21h04 c'est votre version version
dernière témoin et votre version alors
qu'elle est votre version de cette
histoire qui prend une tournure
incroyable alors ma version donc j'étais
j'étais à la clinique donc moi je
travaille plus je travaille plus à la
clinique j'étais venu juste simplement
dire bonjour à mes anciens collègues
j'étais à l'étage donc là quand je vous
ai expliqué je vois docteur Wana donc
effaré descend les escaliers en train de
enfin on se rhabillant donc je comprends
pas trop ensuite il descend et bon je me
dis bon ben une urgence au bloc
opératoire
donc
j'entends du bruit je descends
et là je le vois donc je vois docteur
Wana madame Stevenson suivi de son frère
devant donc juste devant la voiture et
docteur Rouana disait que le bruit
c'était plus possible qu'il donc les
gestes qui qui montent sur la vidéo qui
disait voilà à l'étage il y a des
passantes qui se plaignent je viens de
faire 5 opérations aujourd'hui enfin
c'est plus possible au bout d'un moment
il faut voilà il faut vivre en France
ouais c'est ça on en peut plus et
ensuite elle a commencé à l'insulter
donc je vais vous épargner les insultes
des insultes elle a commencé donc à nous
cracher dessus donc je lui ai dit mais
en fait enfin vous nous crachez pas
dessus là je suis venu pour calmer les
choses on peut parler calmement donc
elle voulait rien savoir elle continue à
insulter etc et c'est de là après
docteur Rona bah il s'est énervé et j'ai
essayé de calmer moi je me suis pris des
coups et des coups et des coups et des
coups et j'ai essayé de du mieux que je
pouvais en fait de le protéger mais si
c'est pas parce que c'était docteur Wana
ça avait été une autre personne j'aurais
Raji la même manière mais en fait j'ai
juste fait un acte de citoyenneté tout
simplement en fait je suis venu aider
quelqu'un oui mais même avec votre la
version on le voit bien c'est lui qui
rentre chez elle donc
avant on voit pas justement les vidéos
de crachat c'est ça en fait c'est les
vidéos d'insultes les vidéos de crachat
on le voit pas dans les vidéos qu'elle
vous a qu'elle vous a donné ouais c'est
juste devant au niveau devant là il
était 18h un peu plus de 18h quel style
ben espèce de connard vieux con enfin
voilà
je vous dis on a demandé toi aussi tu
bah oui parce que moi j'ai cru le
docteur quand il est venu je l'ai vu en
100 machin avec les trucs je sais c'est
quand même une grosse agression donc je
l'ai cru et il me dit qu'il descend en
blouse de chirurgien je crois et sur les
images je vois quelqu'un qui arrive ça
commence les images c'est le début qu'on
voit je vois quelqu'un qui est assez le
début
des images de mélodie Stevenson c'est le
début c'est pas le début parce que le
début elle est crachat il y a les
insultes
quand j'arrive on me vraiment arrivé sur
les vidéos
en fait elle est coupée c'est à dire que
elle dure beaucoup plus longtemps et la
musique le moteur d'accord à comprendre
qu'il était des gens qui mettent de la
musique et du moteur malheureusement il
y en a partout c'est des chiant qui met
de la musique partout moi ce que j'ai du
mal à comprendre sur la version que nous
a donné le docteur et là je vois
quelqu'un arriver quelqu'un à ouvrir une
voiture et vouloir éteindre une voiture
moi si tu me fais ça je vais dégoupiller
tu rentres pas dans ma voiture pour
éteindre ma voiture déjà tu as pas à
faire ça déjà et après je vois quelqu'un
rentrer dans la maison de quelqu'un si
tu rentres dans ma maison je vais
dégoupiller encore donc je me demande si
c'est le docteur qui a agressé ou si
c'est le docteur qui se fait qui agresse
et qui qui crée ça qui crée cette
situation moi j'étais avec le docteur
quand j'ai vu des images quand j'ai revu
les images hier de la journaliste je me
suis mis du côté de la journée moi là je
vois quelqu'un qui vous vous portez
c'est lui qui s'ouvre pas la portière de
ma voiture il y a quel moment elle
crache là
la vidéo
j'ai du mal en fait on est venu avec des
vidéos sans son et on
donc là c'est le début là c'est vraiment
là donc là c'est le début donc c'est il
vient d'avoir pour lui dire voilà que
mais la voiture c'est ça le truc qu'on
arrive pas à savoir est-ce que la
voiture il y a encore le moteur parce
que c'est allumé hier il ouvre la
voiture parce qu'il y avait justement
son frère dans la voiture il voulait en
fait il voulait même pas parler avec
elle il voulait tout simplement parler
voilà c'est ça à dire on coupe le moteur
quoi alors Benjamin écoutez moi je me
demande toujours à qui profite le crime
je vois pas pourquoi c'est néo-ana bien
sûr un plateau de télévision vous
racontez une histoire épouvantable s'il
est pas vécu quelque chose alors
effectivement il y a il était agressé
c'est un monsieur qui est une carrière
gigantesque il est fortune fête il est
nettoyé fête pourquoi est-ce qu'il va
aller venir sur un plateau et expliquer
qu'il a été agressé alors à moins que
les choses qu'on ne connaisse pas
l'argument c'est parce que sinon il a il
est excuse-moi il est il a énormément
mondial je vois pas pourquoi il va aller
sur un plateau il était visiblement
extrêmement choqué et vous l'avez dit il
a un peu perdu bien sûr un peu perdu
mais je vois pas pourquoi pourquoi il
fait ça donc moi j'aurais choses à dire
qu'effectivement que je pense qu'il dit
la vérité et je vois pas pourquoi il va
aller chercher des noisettes à une
personne franchement c'est impossible
franchement c'est impossible alors
docteur Rona a été reçu plusieurs fois
ben chez vous Cyril là vous avez pu
remarquer quand même la foi la semaine
dernière il était pas dans son état
normal c'est-à-dire qu'il était encore
choqué il y a une adresse
qui est pas une agression il y a une
agression mais il y a une agression
peut-être provoqué par par Monsieur de
chirurgien c'est peut-être lui qui a
provoqué ça en fait non bah en fait moi
je vous adore mais vous êtes son
ancienne salarié vous êtes là voilà on
sait pas si c'est un bon patron pour
vous quel est l'intérêt de rimes non
mais je sais pas peut-être que c'est
loyal ce qui a les loyal vraiment à 100%
mais absolument là je suis venu comme je
lui ai dit je suis pas venu pour parler
pour défendre doctor wanna ou pour
défendre madame Stevenson je suis venu
pour vous dire la vérité de ce qui s'est
passé ma vérité donc c'est ce qui s'est
passé c'est la vérité mais là je vous ai
dit la vérité les crachats les insultes
bah si je vous ai dit ma vérité c'est ma
vérité c'est ma vérité en fait je
raconte il y a pas mal de gens sur les
qui disent Benjamin à mon avis veut une
ristourne pour un nouveau
quand on voit les images on va quand
même c'est extrêmement violent et s'il y
a une victime c'est bien monsieur Ohana
faut pas déconner non plus parce qu'il
faut savoir aussi c'est que là où ils
vivent là c'est un square alors
évidemment quand tu arrives en Ferrari
avec la musique à donf je peux te dire
que tout le monde en profite parce qu'il
y a de l'écho et ça résonne partout
alors je pense que si elle fait ça
souvent
alors mais ça paramètre important si
elle fait ça souvent qui est dans la
peinture d'arriver avec la Ferrari le
bruit que ça fait et la musique dans une
résidence de millionnaire et tu arrives
pas en Ferrari alors
rien pour les téléspectateurs qui nous
rejoignent à 21h10 moi je vous le dis
je peux pas croire qu'il y a pas eu
autre chose bien sûr
qui va dans la voiture il y a eu quelque
chose là oui il y a eu un truc
absolument pas possible absolument la
journaliste a évoqué un lien entre la
dame qui aurait été agressée dans
l'après-midi et le docteur est-ce que
est-ce que ce lien existe réellement et
est-ce qu'il y aurait absolument pas
sinon il y a pas de lire absolument pas
absolument et même pour la petite
histoire
la voisine est docteur Wana était un
petit peu en guerre concernant moi après
des problèmes de syndic mais ils sont
jamais j'aime non alors nous avons une
image aussi où vous êtes fait agresser
par par mélodie est-ce qu'on l'a cette
image merci
incroyable cette histoire
Cyril enfin j'ai rendu c'est à dire que
j'ai essayé de prendre le maximum de
coups que je pouvais pour défendre j'ai
rendu zéro coup enfin vous voyez mon
gabarit c'est-à-dire que j'ai quand même
fait un tour sur moi-même enfin c'est
ça a été très violent c'est très violent
et elle disait que elle m'a donné des
coups sans faire exprès mais là on voit
très bien que c'est pas des coups sans
faire exprès enfin pourquoi il peut
avoir une telle tension je trouve que
c'est sauf que la situation est
disproportionnée
ce qui se passe par rapport à ce qu'on
voit en début on se dit tout si il y a
un truc il y a un élément qu'on a pas
c'est un sentiment qu'on nous dit pas
tout et je voudrais revenir sur ce
détail cette ouverture de portière je
trouve que cinémovana le fait de manière
très naturelle que même mélodie
Stevenson ne réagit pas comme si c'était
normal il y a le fils de cinéa qui
m'appelle
il peut me rappeler dans dans un instant
s'il veut voilà parce que c'est vrai
qu'on a l'impression peut-être qu'il va
nous donner un élément qu'on pas et
c'est vrai que il y a un truc il y a un
truc qu'on capte pas et ce qui nous
cache pas quelque chose sur la nature de
leur relation est-ce qu'ils se
connaissent pas plus qu'on ne le croit
non absolument pas la portière de
quelqu'un comme ça
et elle a même elle l'a dit hier il ne
se connaissent pas
c'est vraiment j'aimerais bien
que je vous dis il a un frère elle a son
frère moi si je vois ma sœur qui a en
difficulté qui a quelqu'un qui l'insulte
et qui on a l'impression qu'ils sont
fous total on passe il fait sa vie il
les comme si bon on le sait on a
l'habitude de de ses embrouilles entre
les deux je vous dis je vous dis sur le
ressenti de de ce qui ressort aussi sur
les réseaux tout le monde dit il a il a
un frère d'1m80 elle a un frère d'un
mètre 90 il voit sa sœur qui se fait
embrouiller c'est incroyable on n'a
jamais vu ça quoi on se dit ou le mec se
dit on se connaît tous les deux bon ils
ont l'habitude ils se connaissent ça va
ça va pas aller loin ou bien il y a rien
il y a un truc c'est la première fois
c'est à dire que c'est vrai que c'est on
a du mal à y croire mais je vous assure
qu'il y a jamais rien eu avant après
monsieur wanana vous avez dit qu'il
connaissait le compagnon de Me de la
journée je tiens à remercier
en fait il le connaissait ouais ils font
des réunions syndic ça veut dire que
voilà en tant que voisin mais il ne se
connaissent pas personnellement encore
une fois
profondément choquée hier j'ai eu une
double peine dans le sens où j'ai été
témoin et agressée et on m'accuse
d'avoir porté un coup de coude le coup
de coude
c'est quand même un coup de tranchant il
a une déplacée enfin il est ouvert c'est
clairement pas moi
un objet tranchant et qu'elle tienne des
propos quand même grave toute la journée
aujourd'hui docteur renard aussi des
menaces de morts
des témoignages des commentaires enfin
ça la profondément choqué sachant que
tout ce qui fait franchement docteur
honnête j'ai jamais vu un homme aussi
généreux que lui
il donne énormément il travaille pour
défendre il est avec des associations
enfin jamais jamais ce qui fait la force
de la clinique Eiffel justement c'est
que il y a une diversité énorme il y a
toutes les toutes les origines toutes
les religions sur un truc qui qui vous a
profondément choqué c'est le fait
qu'elle est dit qu'il ait eu des propos
racistes
clairement faux ça c'est c'est quoi
c'est de l'invention mais c'est de
l'invention pure et dure c'est je suis
encore choqué je suis encore chaud ok
c'est totalement faux c'est grave c'est
grave de tenir des propos enfin les
conséquences sont quand même grave
toutes les menaces de mort les
témoignages les commentaires enfin c'est
c'est quand même et surtout que c'est
faux
c'est ce qu'il maintient encore
aujourd'hui moi j'ai échangé avec lui
aujourd'hui et je voudrais juste dire
que sur les vidéos de Madame Stevenson
ce que on voyait les vidéos qui dit qui
étaient derrière vous il y a des
horaires 18h13 puis 18h23 on voit qu'il
y a des membres et c'est 5 minutes là
qui qui serait la minute du crachat la
minute de l'altercation le ton monte et
après dans la vidéo suivante quand on
les voit sur le perron sur le perron du
domicile de Madame C25 ce que dit
monsieur mais si je rentre sur le perron
à un moment c'est parce que il y a
l'altercation qui commence parce qu'il y
a des insultes parce que je viens de
défendre non non mais c'est ce qu'il dit
non mais j'explique ce qu'il dit donc
c'est vrai qu'on nous raconte deux
histoires différentes très différentes
l'une de l'autre mais bon non il y a pas
d'altercation si vous pouvez remettre la
18h15 au début c'est lui qui rentre dans
la maison c'est il rentre dans la
voiture ce que tu dis moi si tu rentres
chez moi j'ai peu importe tu rentres pas
dans ma voiture et tu rentres pas dans
la maison j'ai l'impression regarde les
images justifie pas ça
justifier l'agression personne et je dis
que l'agression
il n'a pas de geste pour de ce qu'on
voit voilà
après après voilà après c'est vrai que
voilà le début de on comprend pas cette
histoire en fait le dérouler exactement
le séquencier en fait parce que quand il
a débarque comme ça quand il entre dans
le champ et qui va ouvrir directement on
a l'impression qu'il y a un truc de fou
avant parce qu'il s'est passé
pour une voiture qui s'est garé pendant
15 secondes c'est pas 15 secondes
3 minutes ça veut dire le mec il t'a
plus le droit de
vraiment que et ça je le redis ça c'est
important et ça vraiment je le crois
qu'il n'y a jamais eu de propos racistes
déjà voilà je pense pas jamais jamais ça
c'est vraiment le truc qui a le plus
blessé
cinéma j'espère qu'en tout cas ça voilà
ça c'est c'est vrai que c'est dramatique
pour les deux cette affaire et on a vu
voilà l'état de de Sydney on a la
semaine dernière qui était vraiment
salement amoché on se dit voilà que sa
famille a dû être également aussi
choquée on sait pas on n'arrive pas à
savoir ce qui s'est réellement passé
mais en tout cas ce qui est sûr et ce
qui est enfin ce qui est dit vraiment de
votre côté le côté de Sydney et du côté
de sa famille c'est que jamais son père
n'a pu avoir de propos euh voilà
racistes ou déplacé voilà en tout cas
voilà c'est ce qu'il voulait faire
passer comme message aussi ce soir